>> ♪ ♪
>> THIS PRESIDENT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR HAVING OTTO WARMBIER
RETURNED TO THIS COUNTRY TO BE
REUNITED WITH HIS FAMILY IN THE
FINAL HOURS BEFORE HE PASSED.
THE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT
CHAIRMAN KIM DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO OTTO WARMBIER WHEN
IT HAPPENED.
>> KELLYANNE CONWAY, THIS IS THE
CLEAN UP BRIGADE AGAIN.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID WAS
DESPICABLE.
HE HAS A LOVE AFFAIR WITH KIM
JONG-UN WHO IS A BRUTAL DICTATOR
AND WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEATH OF OTTO WARMBIER.
WE SHOULD NOT BE NAIVE ABOUT
THIS REGIME AND THE WAY THEY
MISTREAT THEIR OWN PEOPLE AND
THE WAY THEY MISTREATED OTTO
WARMBIER.
>> Shannon: LET'S BRING IN A
PANEL TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
GENTLEMEN, WELCOME TO ALL OF
YOU.
LET'S START HERE.
OTTO WARMBIER'S PARENTS HAVE HAD
TO WATCH AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRAISED KIM JONG-UN IN CERTAIN
ROCKEFELLER PLAZA.
-- RESPECTS.
THEY SAID WE HAVE BEEN
RESPECTFUL DURING THE SUMMIT.
NOW WE MUST SPEAK OUT.
KIM AND HIS EVIL REGIME ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH OF OUR
OTTO WARMBIER.
NO LAVISH PRAISE CAN CHANGE
THAT.
>> IT'S NOT ONLY THEIR OPINION.
THAT'S WHAT U.S. INTELLIGENCE
FOUND AS WELL.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE REALIZES
THEY NEEDED TO WALK THIS BACK.
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
KIM JONG-UN TOOK THE POSITION
THAT THE CROWN PRINCE OF SAUDI
ARABIA TOOK.
THESE WERE ROGUE UNDERLINGS.
I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
BUT WE KNOW IN NORTH KOREA AND
SAUDI ARABIA NOTHING HAPPENS
WITHOUT THE LEADERSHIP AT THE
TOP KNOWING ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY LYING.
>> Shannon: THE PRESIDENT PUT
OUT 2 TWEETS.
I NEVER LIKE BEING
MISINTERPRETED ESPECIALLY WITH
OTTO WARMBIER.
I GOT OTTO WARMBIER OUT WITH 3
OTHERS.
OF COURSE I HOLD NORTH KOREA
RESPONSIBLE FOR OTTO WARMBIER.
OTTO WARMBIER WILL NOT HAVE DIED
IN VAIN.
HE AND HIS FAMILY ARE A SYMBOL
OF STRENGTH.
I LOVE OTTO WARMBIER AND THINK
OF HIM OVEN.
OFTEN.
IT'S -- HE IS NOT ATTRIBUTING
KNOWLEDGE OF IT TO KIM.
>> EVEN IN 2018 HE SAID WE
PLEDGE TO HONOR OTTO WARMBIER'S
MEMORY.
HE ONLY TALKED ABOUT THE
DICTATORSHIP.
HE'S BEEN TRYINGED TO SHIELD KIM
FROM BLAME OF FROM THIS.
HE SAID HE WOULD NOT HAVE NOTED
TO DID THAT BECAUSE IT WOULD NOT
BE TO HIS DAMAGE TALKING ABOUT
KIM.
ALMOST LIKE LAWYERING ON HIS
BEHALF.
THIS HAS BEEN A CHRONIC PROBLEM
FOR DONALD TRUMP EVER SINCE HE
DECLARED HIS CANDIDACY.
THE WAY HE TALKS THE HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES OF OTHER
COUNTRIES.
HE TENDS TO RELATIVIZE THEM.
WHETHER IT'S THE KINGDOM OF
SAUDI ARABIA.
AN OLD ENEMY LIKE NORTH KOREA OR
EVEN SAYING THAT THE UNITED
STATES KILLED A LOT OF PEOPLE
TOO.
HE IS NOT OVER THAT PROBLEM.
>> Shannon: AND FOR THE HELSINKI
SITUATION, HE IS RELATIONAL.
HIS RELATIONSHIPS ARE THE KEY
FOR HIM TO GET IMPORTANT
CONCESSIONS FOR THE U.S.
HE WON'T INSULT THEM DIRECTLY.
THAT'S HOW HE BELIEVES HE GETS
THE DEAL DONE.
>> THE STRATEGY IS PERSONAL
DIPLOMACY.
HE FOUND THE LIMITS IN THIS
SECOND SUMMIT.
HE TRIED THE TERM APPROACH AND
TRIED TO TALK UP HIS LOVE OF KIM
JONG-UN.
IT STILL DIDN'T GET HIM THE
DOLE.
AS HE CONDUCTS THIS ATTEMPT TO
PROMOTE PEACE IN KOREA.
WE HAVE MOVED ON.AS HE CONDUCTST
WE HAVE MOVED ON.AS HE CONDUCTSE
WE HAVE MOVED ON.AS HE CONDUCTS
PROMOTE PEACE IN KOREA.
WE HAVE MOVED ON.DEAL.
AS HE CONDUCTS THIS ATTEMPT TO
PROMOTE PEACE IN KOREA.
WE HAVE MOVED ON.
HE HAS TOO KEEP IN MIND WHO KIM
IS AND WHO NORTH KOREA ARE.
THEY ARE THE MOST TERRIBLE
VIOLATORS OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> Shannon: THE CONTRAST TO HIS
EFFORTS IN NORTH KOREA WAS
MICHAEL COHEN BEING HERE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND IN
PUBLIC AS WELL.
>> IT WAS A PRODUCTIVE
INTERVIEW.
HE SHED LIGHT ON ISSUES CORE TO
OUR INTRFTION.
-- INVESTIGATION.
>> THE DEMOCRATS INTENTION IS
FOR THIS INVESTIGATION TO GO
THROUGH 2020 INTO THE NEXT
ELECTION.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
IF THEY DON'T FIND EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION WHICH THEY HAVE NOT,
THEN THEY WILL LOOK FOR
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Shannon: THAT MAY BE THE
PRESIDENT'S TAX RETURNS.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR NANCY PELOSI
SAID THEY WILL DO EVERYTHINGS IN
INCLUDING LITIGATION TO GET THE
PRESIDENT'S TAX RETURNS.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
THEY SAID THEY WILL TAKE ALL
NECESSARY STEPS INCLUDING
LITIGATION TO GET THEM.
JASON?
>> THE DEMOCRATS CONTROL MORE
THAN 2 DOZEN COMMITTEES WITH
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY ARE JUST GETTING STARTED.
THEY ARE COMING AFTER TAX
RETURNS AND COMING AFTER THE
TRUMP FAMILY, THE TRUMP
BUSINESS, THE TRUMP FOUNDATION.
SETTING THE GROUND WORK HERE FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
THESE INVESTIGATIONS ARE NOT
ABOUT FINDING ANYTHING NEW.
IT'S ABOUT VOLUME.
HOW MANY CAN WE GO WITH HERE AND
KEEP THEM RUNNING THROUGH THE
ELECTION.
THAT'S THE GOAL.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE ON THE
DEFENSIVE FROM NOW UNTIL 2020.
>> Shannon: THERE WON'T BE A
LINE ON THE TAX RETURN THAT SAYS
$500,000 FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT WON'T BE THERE.
ARE THEY GOING AFTER HIM FOR
BRAGGING HOW SUCCESSFULLY HE IS
FINANCIALLY?
>> I HAVE TO BELIEVE IF THESE
TAX RETURNS REFLECTED WELL, HE
WOULD HAVE PUT THEM IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN.
HE HAS A STRANGE AVERSION TO
DOING WHAT EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT
HAS DONE.
>> Shannon: HE IS UNLIKE ANY
OTHER.
>> NO QUESTION.
I AM SURE THE RETURNS ARE
STACKED THIS HIGH.
STILL, LONG AGO A NORMAL
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE REVEALED
THEM.
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING IN
THERE HE DOESN'T WANT PEOPLE TO
SEE.
SOONER OR LATER MAYBE WE WILL
IT I DISAGREE WITH JASON.
I AM NOT SURE IMPEACHMENT IS THE
DEMOCRAT'S END GAME.
I THINK IS A SUBSTITUTE FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE THEY
HAVE SO MUCH TO WORK WITH.
THEY CAN KEEP IT GOING ALL THE
WAY THROUGH 2020.
>> CONGRESS IS A NUISANCE.